you know legally here at the Rubin
report we have to do one story on the
gays per week so here we go
Russia has actually been doing a ton of
anti LGBT stuff lately all kinds of
crazy laws are coming through it is now
illegal to admit homosexuality in public
this is just a few of them that have
just come in it's illegal to equate the
value of homosexual homosexual
relationships with that of heterosexual
relationships punishment doesn't apply
solely to Russians even foreigners can
be arrested and detained fined and
deported for homosexual activity now the
reason I'm bringing this up is because
as you guys may know the Winter Olympics
in 2014 are gonna be in Sochi Russia and
a lot of people are calling for a
boycott of the Olympics because of this
so the IOC the International Olympic
Committee has issued a statement the
International Olympic Committee is clear
that sport is a human right and should
be available to all regardless of race
sex or sexual orientation the games
themselves should be open to all free of
discrimination and that applies to
spectators officials media and of course
athletes we would oppose in the
strongest terms any move that would
jeopardize this principle okay that
sounds really nice but naturally there
aren't going to be any openly gay
Russian athletes for sure there are a
couple openly gay athletes that we had
in the Summer Olympics but the question
is now that's just a statement it
doesn't sound like they're gonna do
anything about this and does the IOC
have even the power 20 for the 2014
Winter Games are coming I mean this is a
matter of months at this point can we
actually do anything or should we
actually do anything what do you think
yeah I don't think they can do anything
I mean I suppose the LGBT community
could come up with something boycotting
or something like that but I mean every
single country that the IOC goes into
there's some sort of horrific compromise
I mean you know they're gonna be going
to Brazil for the Summer Olympics that's
gonna be very interesting and and this
is just you know it's like it's one
thing about creating
a semi market economy here in Russia now
they're trying to you know open up but
you can still see the mentality and and
the horrific oppression going on in that
country and and it seems to be actively
getting worse that's the darker and
darker like this isn't like an Arab
country where things have been
completely backwards this is what was a
country that was becoming westernized
yeah and years ago that's going the
other way and what in the article what
was the percentage of people it's in the
culture who think that absolutely
homosexuality is like bad we're like
yeah 16:16 it's a small amount of pets
it's a very interesting culture and it's
one that I don't think we can really
wrap our heads around here in the West
yeah so Jerry what do you think the IOC
should do because I mean just in terms
of time forget the just in terms of
logistics
they can't switch the Olympics at this
point and we deal with tons of countries
that do all kinds of horrible things the
hard part I guess because I maybe I'm
maybe I'm hoping for too much but the
way they say sport and the Olympics it
brings the world together you know
regardless of where you're from or what
your background is it's kind of what
your job is so I mean and maybe you
can't eliminate it because there's a lot
of countries in this world and then
maybe I assume you supposed to know be
researched these countries before you
dedicate an Olympics to them alright
this just started I mean maybe this it
was probably four years ago maybe eight
years ago that they decided to go to
Russia for this particular this has
gotten worse since the decision was made
it wasn't like it was great and then it
got kind of bad and now it's worse
I don't think it was ever awesome these
countries have the IOC in and the games
in because it's a big PR campaign well
this isn't working well for Russia but
now because they they know what they're
doing and is it that they're trying you
know so much has changed for gay rights
and especially just in the United States
alone in this past couple months and in
England just passed gay marriage so are
they making a stand that they really are
doubling down on like we're the real
still you know world
and they'll be on the you know they'll
be on the back edge of that because it
you know the world is changing you know
and and there is something about the
idealism of the Olympics I think about
you know we're gonna come and we're
gonna be role models anyway we have an
oh it's like an open society I've heard
at least talk about it's like this
perfect world you live in for two or
three weeks while you're there and you
you are crossing there's no nationality
there's nationality but there really
isn't because you're all athletes so I
think that is a positive thing and I
think that does shift energy in some way
and I think the people from Russia who
come and have that experience you know
maybe some minds will be shifted and
that's a real shame is because I'm a
firm believer that all of the athletes
they can they dedicate their lives
especially Olympic athletes they
dedicate their lives often for very
little or no money to their sport so
they don't care if the person that
they're that's that they're playing
badminton with or give me a winter sport
than bad the news do they care that the
other guy on the luge okay I mean that
just doesn't seem do you think partly
that this story won't get that much
traction because of a little bit of gay
fatigue because I have a little of this
myself that we've come so far in just in
the last few months so many good things
have happened here in America and again
I'm not trying to make everything about
America but it also happened in England
and it's happening around the world
South America other places that maybe
you just have to let some of the things
go that maybe the the gay think has to
just sort of let this one go and keep
working on the other I think it actually
balances itself out I mean you have you
have people that are pushing every day
because that's their life that's what
they're trying to do and then so then
you have people that as you said maybe
have the fatigue but in the people that
are pushing the people that are pulling
back you may be gonna find a balance
no one should pull back if they believe
in what they're doing because it's
what's needed it's what has to happen
so in this happening you have to it's
gonna slowly change is this may not
happen right away which is because we
have a lot of people that are tired of
it or just are [ __ ] you need to pick
your battles to win the war and this is
okay this is one
it's one but there's been a lot of
battles one recently and it's okay to
actually enjoy that yeah and you think
it might actually strengthen the war if
you lose this battle because if you
don't allow gay people to participate or
if you're jailing gay people that show
up the other you actually are
strengthening the movement for equality
so I think this is good now there's a
spotlight yeah what's gonna happen I
mean there was a I think one of it one
of the LGBT the groups and the in these
articles was saying this is gonna get
serious it was just giving a warning
shot
this is gonna get serious yeah and left
it alone and when I get serious and who
knows what may happen hope nothing yeah
then people gonna remember hey they said
there's gonna be a series maybe we
should listen to these guys right
unfortunately sometimes you need some
bad stuff to happen to get you good
stuff to come back